This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个I-Heart播客。100%保证是人类创作。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析在当今这个奇妙的现代世界中，如何培养心理韧性、保持体能以及构筑抗压能力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你会以一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的姿态涅槃重生。收听《2%》。也就是数字2%。在iHeartRadio、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上搜索。欢迎收听《Look Back at It》播客。从1979年开始，那对我和1984年来说都是意义重大的时刻。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每集我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着去理解我们是如何挺过来的。和我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜爱的作家们一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。1984年是一个疯狂的年份。那确实是一个疯狂的年份。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. does not mean that you need to listen to learn the hard way on the aha radio app apple podcast or wherever
在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方订阅《Look Back at It》。嘿，大家最近怎么样？欢迎收听由你喜爱的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯主持的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个节目旨在探讨黑人群体的真实经历，进行那些在任何地方公开讨论都不太安全的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一个深谙此道的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人背负着一副重甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。但这并不意味着你拥有这种能力，就一定代表你必须去这样做。收听iHeartRadio、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方播放的《Learn the Hard Way》。
you get your podcast hello and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology hello everybody welcome back to the show welcome back to the podcast it's so great to have you here thank you for tuning in for a new episode of the psychology of your 20s. If you're a new listener, if you're an old listener, it is great to have you here. Today, we are talking about a topic that you, you the listeners, actually chose on my Instagram, one that I am really, really interested in at the moment. Often the topics that I find the most fascinating and I enjoy researching the most of those that are really like kind of personally
哈喽，欢迎回到《The Psychology of Your 20s》，这是一个与大家探讨二十多岁时人生重大改变与过渡，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么的播客。大家好，欢迎回到节目中，欢迎收听本期播客，很高兴能在这里与大家相聚。感谢大家收听《The Psychology of Your 20s》的新一期节目。无论你是新听众还是老听众，很高兴有你陪伴。今天，我们要讨论一个你们这些听众在我的Instagram上亲自投票选出的主题，这也是我目前非常非常感兴趣的一个话题。通常情况下，那些让我觉得最着迷、最享受去深入研究的主题，恰恰是那些作为二十多岁的年轻人，与我有着非常直接、
relevant to me as someone in my 20s. So I hope that you enjoy this as well. But today, we're going talk about that sharp sting of rejection, something I think we are all inevitably going to experience in our 20s. I imagine for many of you, you're thinking about a particular experience right now. And often when we think about rejection, it's to do with romantic love and intimate relationships. Perhaps there is a time in your life where you've been rejected by a potential love interest. You know, you've been turned down after you took a leap of faith and asked someone out. or maybe it's rejection from a long-term partner. Often rejection in social situations is going to be the most painful.
切身关联的事情。所以我希望你们也会喜欢这个话题。但今天，我们要聊聊那种尖锐的、刺痛人心的被拒绝感——我认为这是我们在二十多岁时都不可避免会经历的事情。我想象你们中的许多人，此刻脑海中正在浮现出某段特定的经历。通常当我们想到拒绝时，它都与浪漫的爱情和亲密关系有关。也许你的人生中曾有过这样的时刻：你向一个心仪的对象表白，却遭到了拒绝。你知道的，当你鼓起勇气向某人表白却被婉拒；或者也许是被长期伴侣抛弃。通常在社交场合中，被拒绝带来的痛苦往往是最深刻的。
And that's not just what people we're dating or that we're interested in, but friends as well. Feeling left out and socially rejected or like you're not wanted around, that can leave some pretty deep, pretty painful wounds for many reasons. I'm sure you can think back to a time that you have experienced. experience rejection and very vividly relate to that sense of hopelessness, that pain, that dejection, and maybe it's comforting to you to know there is a science behind that. There is psychology behind why we feel this way, and we're going to discuss it here today. We as humans, we really do crave connection with every fiber of our being. It's so crucial to our mental
而且这不仅限于我们正在约会或感兴趣的人，朋友之间也是如此。那种被排挤、在社交上被拒绝，或是感觉自己不被需要的体验，由于种种原因，可能会留下相当深重、相当痛苦的伤痕。我确信你能回想起自己曾经历过被拒绝的时刻，并且能非常生动地体会到那种无助感、痛苦感、沮丧感。也许了解这一切背后其实有科学依据，能给你带来一丝安慰。为什么我们会产生这种感受，背后是有心理学依据的，我们今天就会在这里探讨它。我们作为人类，内心深处对人际连接有着极其强烈的渴望。这对于我们的心理
health, our physical, spiritual, social health and happiness, but also our sense of belonging, our sense of social security. So when we're denied that opportunity, it can be especially painful because instinctually, we see social rejection in particular as a threat to our survival and the availability of community, the availability of support. We're going to talk about many of these situations and a lot more today. I also believe the experience of rejection has a really close relationship to our self-esteem and social acceptance theory, things that are really crucial in this formative decade of our lives. So learning how to navigate this inevitable experience is really crucial during this time, especially when we kind of cast our minds forward and think about
健康、生理、精神、社交健康以及幸福感至关重要，同时也关系到我们的归属感和社交安全感。因此，当我们被剥夺这种机会时，痛苦往往会格外深刻，因为出于本能，我们特别是将社交拒绝视为对我们生存以及社群和支持资源可获得性的威胁。我们今天要讨论许多这样的情况以及更多内容。我也相信，被拒绝的经历与我们的自尊心以及社会接受理论有着非常紧密的联系，这些在我们人生中这个塑造性的十年里至关重要。因此，学会如何应对这种不可避免的经历在这个时期真的至关重要，特别是当我们把目光投向未来，思考
the long-term harm that continuous rejection and unaddressed rejection can have on our mindset, can have on our attitudes as well. But also our willingness to pursue. pursue opportunities with work and our careers and areas as broad as, you know, the confidence to travel, to be independent and trust our judgment. Trusting our judgment, that is going to come up quite a bit in this episode. And it can be the undoing of so many important elements of our growth and our well-being. So although we're definitely going to talk about why rejection can be painful, why it can be harmful. We're also going to take a strengths-based approach, as we always do, because this show is
持续的拒绝以及未经处理的拒绝会对我们的心态和态度造成长远的不良影响。同时，它也会影响我们追求工作、职业发展等机遇的意愿，以及诸如拥有旅行的勇气、保持独立并信任自己判断力等广泛领域的信心。信任自己的判断力，这在本期节目中会经常被提及。它可能会摧毁我们成长和幸福感中许多至关重要的元素。因此，尽管我们肯定会讨论为什么拒绝会带来痛苦、为什么它会具有伤害性，但我们也将一如既往地采用基于优势的方法，因为这个节目
about growth and vulnerability and agency. And I really, I really am truly of the firm, firm belief that rejection is really just redirection. It truly is. And there are so many ways to strengthen our mindset towards rejection, to no longer see it as a setback, but as an opportunity a new beginning. I often think about. this time in my final year of uni when I was rejected from this job that I really, really wanted. And at the time it stung, it was really painful. My self-confidence kind of plummeted. I was left with all of this self-doubt.
关乎成长、脆弱感和自主性。而且我真的、真的非常坚信，拒绝实际上只是生活的重新定向。事实确实如此。面对拒绝，我们有很多方法来强化自己的心态，不再将其视为挫折，而看作是一个机遇、一个新的开始。我常常回想起大学最后一年时的这段经历，当时我被一份我非常、非常渴望得到的工作拒绝了。在当时，这真的很刺痛我，非常痛苦。我的自信心可以说是直线下降，留下的只有满腹的自我怀疑。
You know, this is what I'd been working towards. I think about the partners and the people I've pursued that I've really liked that have ended with rejection. And it hurt. It really hurt. But, oh, my gosh, was it such a blessing? such a blessing that those things did not work out. I'm so grateful now for that rejection, even if at the time it was painful, because I never would have arrived here right now,
你知道的，这就是我一直为之努力的目标。我想起那些我曾追求过、非常喜欢却最终以被拒绝告终的伴侣和人们。这确实很痛，真的非常痛。但是，天哪，这简直是一大福分！那些事情没有成功，简直是一大福分。我现在对当初的拒绝充满了感激，即使在当时它是痛苦的，因为如果不是那样，我绝不可能走到今天，
you know, speaking to you. So strap in, get ready to hopefully learn something and explore the internal and also the external world of rejection in our 20s. So I think a really important place to begin is exploring some of the typical situations and events in which we typically and sometimes experience rejection and what kind of impact this can have on us and why we feel it so deeply. Often it's the things that are most important to us, our relationships, our community, our work, our dreams and future, where we're going to feel that sting of rejection, the most acutely, the most sharply. And this makes sense, right? You know, the bigger the investment, the greater the reliance on this area, I guess,
在这里和你对话。所以，系好安全带，准备好去学习一些新知识，并探索我们二十多岁时既内向又外向的被拒绝的世界。因此，我认为一个非常重要的切入点是，去探讨一些我们通常会经历被拒绝的典型情境和事件，以及这类经历会给我们带来什么样的影响，为什么我们会对其感受得如此深刻。通常情况下，那些对我们最重要的事情——我们的关系、我们的社群、我们的工作、我们的梦想和未来——往往是我们最深刻、最强烈地感受到被拒绝刺痛的地方。这其实很好理解，对吧？你知道的，投入越大，为了幸福感对该领域的依赖也就越大，
for happiness, the heart of the fall, the greater the loss, the greater the hurt. And a lot of those aspects that we just mentioned are so crucial in our 20s, especially as we're establishing independent lives, the lives that we want for ourselves. I remember when I was in high school, I was thinking about the unies that I wanted to attend
摔得越惨，损失就越大，痛苦也就越深。而我们刚才提到的许多方面在我们二十多岁时是如此关键，尤其是当我们正着手建立独立的生活、追求我们想要的生活时。我还记得上高中时，我一直在考虑我想去哪些大学，
and, you know, how I could, afford to support myself in Australia. It's not that common actually for people to move out of their hometowns or their cities to go to uni. It's really expensive. It's not something that people typically do, but I really wanted to do it. And I found this amazing scholarship at my dream uni, and I put a lot of pressure on myself to get it, essentially. I placed a lot of my self-worth in being able to obtain this achievement. And I think we can all imagine. and how this story ends. I didn't get it and I felt rejected. Like, I didn't belong in this group of people or even at this uni. And maybe you've experienced something similar when
以及在澳大利亚我该如何负担得起自己的生活费。事实上，人们为了上大学而搬离家乡或城市并不那么常见。这真的很昂贵，通常人们不会这么做，但我真的很想实现它。我在我梦想的大学里找到了这个惊人的奖学金，为此我给自己施加了很大的压力。基本上，我将很大一部分自我价值都押在了能否取得这一成就上。我想我们大家都能想象得到
applying for colleges and university and you feel that this rejection of not getting in reflects pulling on you. It's something you need to fix, something that you're lacking. But often, I think it just means you're not in the right place for you and it's not destiny. Maybe they've overlooked something about you or not understood how truly wonderful you are. Maybe it's also something beyond your control. I think that is particularly the case when it comes to jobs. Often we apply for jobs, we don't get them and we're like, well, I wasn't a good candidate because they didn't like me.
这个故事的结局。我没有得到它，我感到了被拒绝。就像，我不属于这个群体，甚至不属于这所大学。也许你在申请高校时也经历过类似的经历，你会觉得这种落选的拒绝是在否定你自身。这是你需要修复的、你所欠缺的东西。但通常，我认为这只是意味着你并不在真正适合你的地方，这不是命中注定。也许他们漏掉了你身上的一些闪光点，或者没有真正理解你是多么的优秀。也许这也是某些超乎你控制的事情。我认为在求职时尤其如此。通常我们申请工作，没有被录用，我们就会想：好吧，我不是一个好候选人，因为他们不喜欢我。
I wasn't personable enough. I don't have enough achievements. But it might just be that they want someone who can work certain hours or who has some knowledge of some like niche Excel equation and you will find your place eventually. And with romantic partners, I think that is a whole other ballgame, a whole other game in itself, especially since intimate relationships and dating can require and do require so much vulnerability, both with the other person, but also with ourselves, allowing yourself to be open to the possibility of love and acceptance, preparing yourself for
我不够随和。我的成就还不够多。但可能只是因为他们需要一个能上特定班次或者掌握某些冷门Excel函数的人，而你终究会找到属于自己的位置。至于浪漫关系的伴侣，我认为这完全是另一码事，是完全不同的领域，特别是由于亲密关系和约会可以而且确实需要付出极大的脆弱感，既要向对方敞开心扉，也要向自己坦白，让自己去迎接爱情和接纳的可能性，为之做好心理准备，
that, and then being rejected can leave a really sour taste in our mouth and be quite profoundly wounding. Often it's not to do with you. I'm going to say that really clearly. It's not to do with you, but then. But our brains don't always deal well with that ambiguity and want an explanation for things. So often we look for something that can explain an unexpected experience like this. And that's when we might start to think there's something wrong with us, that we did something wrong, we were awkward or they didn't find us attractive or funny or intelligent enough. And what comes from this can be these really self-limiting and harmful beliefs about ourselves. Like I said, the greater the investment and expectation, the greater the value we place on something
然后却遭到拒绝，这会给我们留下一种相当苦涩的滋味，并且造成相当深重的创伤。通常这与你本身无关。我要非常明确地指出这一点。这与你无关，但是呢。但是我们的大脑并不总是能很好地处理这种含糊不清的情况，并且渴望对事物找到一个解释。因此，我们经常会寻找能够解释这种意料之外经历的原因。也就是在那时，我们可能会开始认为我们自己出了问题，是我们做错了什么，是我们表现得不够大方，或者他们觉得我们不够有吸引力、不够有趣、也不够聪明。而由此产生的，正是这些关于我们自己的、极具自我限制性和破坏性的信念。就像我说的，投入和期望越大，我们赋予某事物的价值（
particularly love, the more rejection is likely to sting. And I'll be honest with you, I've had experiences like this quite a few times. And often at the end of it, I would convince myself that if I was skinny, or I liked their hobbies more or their friends liked me if I was more athletic than they would want to be with me. But honestly, I think at the end of the day, we want someone to like us for who we are. It reminds, like I always think about this lyric by this Australian band called ballpark music and this line that kind of really comforts me, which is, I love you exactly as you are.
特别是爱情）就越高，被拒绝时感到的刺痛感往往就越深。说实话，我也曾好几次经历过类似的事情。通常在事情结束后，我会说服自己，如果我再苗条一点，或者我更喜欢他们的爱好，或者如果他们的朋友更喜欢我，如果我更有运动细胞，他们就会愿意和我在一起。但老实说，我认为归根结底，我们是希望有人能因为我们本来的样子而喜欢我们。这让我想起，我总是会想起澳大利亚一支名为Ballpark Music的乐队的一句歌词，这句歌词给了我很大的安慰：“我爱你原本的模样。”
And I know it sounds sappy. I know it sounds really weird. But listen to that song. experiencing romantic rejection because that's what it should feel like when someone really likes you for who you are. But no matter how many times we repeat that sentiment, no matter how many times we feel like we are worthy and we know our worth, rejection across any domain of our life, not just the ones I've talked about, is going to hurt. So let's talk about why, especially some of the science. So rejection and physical pain,
我知道这听起来很肉麻。我知道这听起来真的很奇怪。但去听听那首歌吧。经历浪漫关系的拒绝，因为当真正有人因为你的本色而喜欢你时，就应该是这种感觉。然而，无论我们重复这句话多少次，无论我们多少次觉得自己是有价值的、清楚自己的价值所在，在生命的任何领域——不仅仅是我刚才谈到的那些——遭受拒绝，都是会受伤的。所以，让我们来聊聊为什么会这样，特别是其中的科学原理。因此，拒绝和身体疼痛，
use the same pathways in our brain. I know that sounds really bizarre, but think about a time when, you know, maybe you haven't been invited to something or you felt left out. Like, it physically can hurt. Like you feel this, like pain in your chest, your brain feels all fuzzy.
在我们的脑海中会使用相同的神经通路。我知道这听起来很离谱，但想想看，当你没有被邀请参加某个活动，或者感觉自己被排挤在外的时候。那种感觉真的会在身体上带来痛感。就像你感觉到胸口有一阵疼痛，你的大脑感到一片混乱。
So this group of scientists did these fMRI studies that basically tracks, which, yeah, basically where our brains are using oxygen and that's kind of correlated to what neural pathways were using at the time. and they used this technology to show that the same areas of our brain that become activated when we stab our toe or when we cut our finger or experiencing any kind of physical pain, those pathways are also activated by rejection,
于是，这群科学家进行了这些fMRI（功能性磁共振成像）研究，基本上是追踪我们的脑部在哪些区域消耗氧气，这与我们当时使用的神经通路相关。他们利用这项技术表明，当我们脚趾踢到硬物、手指被割破或经历任何身体疼痛时，大脑中被激活的相同区域，也会被拒绝所激活，
which means they're going to activate a similar feeling within us. And that's why it hurts. That's why it physically hurts because there's a neurological backing to that experience. Our brain relates the pain of rejection, with physical pain and respond so similarly. It's also, I think some of that, that negative experience, that discomfort that comes particularly with social rejection, it destabilizes this fundamental need to belong
这意味着它们会在我们体内激发出相似的感受。这就是为什么它会痛。这就是为什么它会在生理上产生痛感，因为这种体验有着神经学上的依据。我们的大脑将遭受拒绝的痛楚与身体的疼痛联系在一起，并做出了如此相似的反应。同时，我认为那种伴随社交拒绝而来的负面体验和不适感，会动摇我们对归属感的根本需求
and this need to have community. It is so fundamental, no matter how much you try and convince yourself that you're happy alone, you're independent, you don't need anyone, you're hardwired to need people. You're hardwired to need community. So the disconnection that is experienced when we experience rejection, it destabilizes that need, that craving, that like fundamental desire. And that's why we feel emotional pain.
以及对社群的需求。这是如此根本的需求，无论你如何试图说服自己你一个人过得很开心、你很独立、你不需要任何人，你的基因里就是注定需要别人的。你的基因里就注定需要社群。因此，当我们经历拒绝时所体验到的这种断裂感，会动摇这种需求、这种渴望、这种根本的欲望。这就是为什么我们会感受到情感上的痛苦。
And this has really deep links to social acceptance theory as well. So social acceptance, basically it is the degree to which our behaviour is perceived by others to be acceptable and the degree to which we are kind of brought into the group, the degree to which we are brought into social interactions and are able to have a group relationship. And there's so many barriers to this, you know, especially prejudice and stigma and racism. But we will do anything. We really will do anything to, you know, to complete and fulfill that desire of acceptance and approval, particularly from, peers and particularly from people whose social acceptance we really want and often those are people who don't give it freely those are the people who we have to work for social acceptance because we see it as more valuable and we can find that we do things that we don't want to do or because we're trying to fulfill this need to be part of a community to belong to be accepted there's many ways
这与社会接受理论也有着很深的渊源。所以，社会接受，基本上它是指我们的行为被他人认为是可以接受的程度，以及我们被接纳融入群体的程度，也就是我们被带入社交互动并能够建立群体关系的程度。这其中有许多障碍，特别是偏见、污名化和种族主义。但是，为了完成和满足那种对接纳和认可的渴望，我们什么都愿意做，特别是来自同伴的认可，以及来自那些我们真心渴望获得其社会接受的人的认可——通常这些人并不轻易给予认可，我们需要为之付出努力才能赢得他们的社会接受，因为我们认为这种接受更有价值。我们会发现自己会去做一些其实并不想做的事情，仅仅是因为我们试图满足成为社群一部分、获得归属感和被接受的需求。解决这个问题有很多方法，
around this and I know it can feel particularly awful, especially if these are people you really like, or you don't really feel like you belong anywhere. But reconnecting with those who do love us, reaching out to members of a group that already accept us, maybe that's family, maybe that's friends, people we share our values with who know us, can kind of help to soothe that pain of rejection, especially from a group that perhaps we don't want to, you know, maybe probably don't want to be a part of if they don't like you for who you are. There's a deeper science to this as well. So we've talked about social acceptance. We've talked about rejection, destabilizing our need to belong. But when we think about rejection in a romantic context, especially, it used to serve
我知道这感觉可能会特别糟糕，尤其是当这些人是你真的很喜欢的人，或者你真的觉得自己在哪里都找不到归属感的时候。但是，重新与那些真正爱我们的人建立联系，向那些已经接纳我们的群体成员（也许是家人，也许是朋友，或是那些与我们分享价值观、真正了解我们的人）倾诉，可以在一定程度上帮助我们抚平被拒绝的痛苦——尤其是来自某个可能我们根本不想与之同流合污的群体的拒绝，如果他们并不喜欢你本来的样子的话。这背后还有更深层次的科学原理。所以我们谈到了社会接受。我们谈到了拒绝会动摇我们对归属感的需求。但是，当我们从浪漫关系的角度来思考拒绝时，它在过去曾发挥过
a pretty vital function in the past back when we were, you know, hunters and gatherers and, you know, running around trying to find a meal, it was important to have other people. around you to support your survival, right? Like the more people you're associated with, if you have a partner, the more protection you have, the more food you're able to gather, there's like a caregiving role there. So when you weren't accepted by the group, especially when you felt rejected by a potential romantic interest or a sexual interest, which would allow the group to build itself, that was basically the same as a death sentence. If you were pushed away from the group, then you were out on your own.
相当关键的功能。早在我们还是猎人、采集者、到处奔波寻找食物的年代，身边有其他人来支持你的生存至关重要，对吧？就像你交往的人越多，如果你有一个伴侣，你获得的保护就越多，你能收集到的食物就越多，其中存在着一种照顾的角色。因此，当你没有被群体接受，特别是当你感到被潜在的浪漫或性吸引对象（这能让群体自我繁衍）拒绝时，基本上就等于被判了死刑。如果你被群体排挤在外，那么你就只能孤身一人，
own and it's very, you know, pretty low chances of survival there. I think we're surrounded by a lot of technology now and we don't really feel like where those same kind of like cave people back in the day, but our brains are still the same, particularly the center of our brain, which is like the midbrain, that like the old brain is what they call it. So when we, you know, used to be these creatures hunting, hunting and gathering and whatnot, um, our brains develop. to be able to sense the alert and alert us to potential rejection or ostracism because it was important for us to adapt to that situation and not experience rejection. So now, because that function in our brain is still very much there,
孤立无援，生存几率非常渺茫。我想我们现在周围环绕着许多科技，我们不再觉得自己像过去那些穴居人了，但我们的大脑仍然是一样的，特别是我们大脑的中心——也就是中脑，人们称之为“原始脑”。所以，当我们过去扮演着那些狩猎、采集等等的生物时，我们的大脑进化出了一种能力，
it's still very much active, it hasn't gone anywhere. When we experience rejection that's probably not going to lead us to death is probably not going to lead us to be completely shunned, our brain still wants us to react to that. And the way that it gets us to react to that is by using, those pain receptors in our brain to almost shock us, to get our attention by mimicking physical harm. And the people who developed this when they, you know, back in the olden times, they had an evolutionary advantage because they were able to correct their behavior when they sensed rejection
能够感知并提醒我们注意潜在的拒绝或排挤，因为对我们来说，适应这种局势并且避免遭受拒绝至关重要。因此，现在，由于大脑中的这种功能依然完好无存地存在着，它依然高度活跃，并没有消失。当我们经历的拒绝可能不会导致我们死亡、可能不会导致我们被完全放逐时，我们的大脑仍然希望我们对此做出反应。而它促使我们做出反应的方式，就是利用我们大脑中的那些疼痛感受器来给我们一个类似电击的刺激，通过模仿身体受到的伤害来吸引我们的注意力。而那些在远古时代发展出这种机制的人，在进化上占据了优势，因为当他们感知到拒绝时，他们能够纠正自己的行为，
because of those kind of pain, that pain that we experience. And they were more likely to be integrated back into the group, more likely to be accepted by a partner. And that kind of explains why even now there is an evolutionary reaction to any experience of rejection and also why we remember rejection so well. When we think about perhaps a time when I don't know we were dating someone or like kind of started seeing someone and like after like a couple of months they're like yeah, no, this isn't for me. I'm sure we've all had that experience and like when you think about it, I'm sure you can feel that sting in your body. You can feel it somewhere and I'm not asking you. you to relive a traumatic experience, but it is something that's important to understand,
正是因为这种痛苦，那种我们所经历的痛苦。而且他们更有可能重新融入群体，更有可能被伴侣接受。这就解释了为什么即使在今天，对于任何被拒绝的经历，仍然会产生一种进化的反应，以及为什么我们对拒绝的记忆会如此深刻。当我们回想起某段经历，比如我们不知道曾与某人约会，或者开始和某人交往，但在几个月后，对方说：“是的，不，这不适合我。”我确信我们都有过这种经历，当你回想起来时，我确信你能在身体里感受到那种刺痛。你能在某个地方感觉到它，我并不是要求你
because that is exactly what this evolutionary feeling is trying to mimic. Our brain wants us to prioritize experiences of rejection because it's a threat. It used to be a threat. And that's often why when we experience severe rejection, be that in your dating life, in your social life, professional or life, we can often experience a bit of a mental plunge. And that's often accompanied by a lapse in self-confidence and self-worth as our brains and minds try and incorporate that experience, try and learn from it. And in some ways, this unconscious kind of response to rejection is useful. And it used to be useful when we wanted an opportunity to correct our behavior and remain in the in-group. but I think nowadays it can also be quite harmful and create, you know, a lot of self-doubt
去重温一段创伤经历，但这是非常重要去理解的一点，因为这正是这种进化的本能在试图模仿的东西。我们的大脑希望我们将被拒绝的经历放在首位，因为这是一个威胁。过去它是一个威胁。这也是为什么当我们遭受严重的拒绝时，无论是在你的约会生活中、社交生活中、职业生活中，我们常常会经历一段心理上的低谷。伴随而来的往往是自信心和自我价值感的滑坡，因为我们的大脑和思想正试图整合那段经历，并从中吸取教训。在某种程度上，这种对拒绝的无意识反应是有用的。在过去，当我们想要有机会纠正自己的行为并留在内群体中时，它是很有用的，
because if we hold on to that experience for longer than required, it can also lead to future hesitancy towards opportunities and, you know, perhaps wonderful experiences if we're so worried about things going wrong, or we're so worried that we're going to be pushed out, we're going to experience that painful rejection, no matter how optimistic we may be, no matter how much we bounce back, our brain still wants us to be prepared for the worst. And there's a term for this, especially for people who've experienced repeated rejections and now feel like pretty intense hesitancy towards new experiences. It's called learnt helplessness.
但我认为在当今时代，它也可能会相当具有破坏性，并产生大量的自我怀疑，因为如果我们抓住这段经历不放的时间超过了必要限度，它也可能导致我们对未来的机遇产生犹豫不决，甚至对美好的经历也心存疑虑。如果我们太担心事情会出错，或者太担心自己会被排挤、会经历那种痛苦的拒绝，无论我们多么乐观，无论我们多么能够重整旗鼓，我们的大脑仍然希望我们为最坏的情况做好准备。对于这种情况有一个专有名词，特别是对于那些经历过反复拒绝、现在对新体验感到相当强烈犹豫的人来说。这被称为习得性无助。
And it's a reaction from repeated rejection. So these psychologists, they discovered using dogs that If these dogs were tied up while they were, you know, given electric shocks and made to feel pain and weren't able to escape, even after the collar or the chain had been removed and they could have easily ran away, they still continued to suffer through that pain. So learned helplessness, that kind of refers to this condition that we have as humans where if we've learnt that we're going to experience rejection no matter what, you know, we've had so many times where we've dated someone for a person. a few months and then it's ended, we basically begin to view our actions as completely ineffective. We have no effect on what actually occurs or what actually happens. So eventually we just stop trying. We stop trying to avoid those harmful experiences and we tend to believe that that's normal,
这是对反复拒绝的一种反应。所以这些心理学家通过实验发现，如果把狗绑起来，在它们遭受电击和痛苦却无法逃脱时，即使后来解开了项圈或链子，它们本可以轻而易举地逃跑，但它们仍然继续忍受着那种痛苦。因此，习得性无助，指的就是人类身上这种状况：如果我们已经了解到无论如何都会经历拒绝（你知道，我们经历过很多次和一个人交往几个月然后又结束了的情况），我们基本上开始认为自己的行为完全是无能为力的。我们对实际发生的事情或结果没有任何影响力。最终我们就会停止尝试。我们停止尝试去逃避那些有害的体验，并倾向于认为那是正常的，
that that is something that is unavoidable and we may as well just get used to it. I think after facing rejection, we often feel that our actions had no impact. They didn't produce the desired effect. And as a result, we lose hope in situations and it can really kind of get us down. This is often stronger for people with rejection sensitivity disorder or dysphoria. So, you know, I think everyone who is rejected from something, be that a job, maybe your family, your friends, by a partner, by a university, a college, whatever it may be. It's going to hurt. like we've explained this like instinctually and evolutionarily our brains are going to respond to that but
那是无可避免的事情，我们不如干脆习惯它。我想在面对拒绝之后，我们经常会觉得自己的行为没有任何影响。它们没有产生预期的效果。结果，我们对局势失去了希望，这确实会让我们情绪低落。对于患有拒绝敏感性焦虑或烦躁不安症的人来说，这种感觉往往会更强烈。所以，你知道，我认为每一个被某事拒绝的人，无论是被工作、也许是家人、朋友、伴侣、大学、高校拒绝，无论是什么，
there are some people who experience this much more intensely and it actually leads to them being fearful of rejection so much so that they avoid situations out of fear of rejection individuals with this high rejection sensitivity that's what it's called they kind of constantly look for signs and look for like early indicators that they're going to be rejected. They have a greater physical response to those feelings, including intense anxiety and intense discomfort. And there's been heaps of explanations as to why there are some people who are better at managing rejection and some people who really struggle with it. Some of the explanations kind of rest on emotional sensitivity, which isn't a bad thing. It's a beautiful thing,
都会感到痛苦。正如我们所解释的，我们的本能和进化决定了我们的大脑会对之做出反应，但有些人对此体验得更加强烈，以至于这导致他们对拒绝产生恐惧，甚至因为害怕被拒绝而逃避各种情况。患有这种高度拒绝敏感性的人（这就是它的称呼）会不断寻找遭到拒绝的迹象和早期征兆。他们对这些感受有着更强烈的身体反应，包括剧烈的焦虑和极大的不适感。对于为什么有些人更善于处理拒绝而有些人却苦苦挣扎，已经有许许多多的解释。其中一些解释基于情感敏感性——这并不是一件坏事。它是一件美好的事情，
but it can make us a lot more sensitive to these situations, having an attention bias, to rejection so we don't look at, we don't think about all those times when everything worked out well, when, you know, everyone loved us at that party or a partner accepted us for who we are, we only think about the bad times. And finally, it can often come from people who've experienced some kind of childhood trauma or have some kind of childhood vulnerability, particularly after parental rejection. And this has created almost a fear response in them, this learnt instantaneous response. We talk about this in the overcoming childhood trauma episode if you're interested in learning more about it. So these people, they experience more distress essentially, and it can also lead to harmful people-pleasing
但它确实会让我们对这些情况更加敏感，并对拒绝抱有注意力偏差，这意味着我们不会去关注、不会去思考那些一切顺利的时刻，比如每个人在派对上都喜欢我们，或者伴侣接纳了我们本来的模样，我们只去想那些糟糕的时刻。最后，这种情况通常源于那些经历过某种童年创伤或存在某种童年脆弱性的人，特别是在遭受父母拒绝之后。这在他们体内几乎创造了一种恐惧反应，一种习得的瞬时反应。如果你有兴趣了解更多，我们在“克服童年创伤”那一期节目中讨论过这个。因此，这些人本质上会经历更多的痛苦，这也可能导致有害的讨好行为，牺牲自己的需求，更愿意去牺牲他人，从而使他们自己陷入高度脆弱的境地。如果我们如此害怕被拒绝，我们往往会根据受众来迎合自己的行为，而无法保持真实的自我。
behaviors and sacrificing their own needs, wanting to sacrifice those of others more, and put them in a position of great vulnerability. If we're so scared of rejection, often we kind of cater our behaviors to our audience and we're not able to remain our true selves. I don't know. I think about job interviews where like we try and create a bit of a persona or, you know, meeting new people where we try and pretend we're something we're not because we're kind of fearful that they won't like us. And we care a lot about whether they like us. But it can be really harmful. Yeah, it can be really harmful. So let's explore some of the long-term impacts of rejection. Not only on our, on our brains and our minds, but also on our perspectives, on our well-being, and on our mindsets.
我不知道。我想到了面试，我们会试图塑造某种假象，或者在结识新朋友时，我们试图假装自己不是那种人，因为我们担心他们会不喜欢我们。而且我们在乎他们是否会喜欢我们。但这可能会非常具有破坏性。是的，它可能真的很有破坏性。因此，让我们探讨一下被拒绝的一些长远影响。不仅对我们的头脑和心灵，而且对我们的视角、幸福感和心态的影响。
Our next partner has a product I use literally every day. I started taking AG1 because I've been on a bit of a health journey. I wanted to take better care of my immune system and my gut health. And with one delicious scoop of AG1, you're essentially absorbing 75 high-quality vitamins, minerals, probiotics, all that good stuff. And it's really great for your nervous system and your immune system. just one simple micro habit that you can incorporate into your daily life with big benefits. It's super lifestyle friendly and Athletic Greens is also a climate neutral certified company,
我们的下一个合作伙伴拥有一款我每天都在使用的产品。我开始服用AG1，因为我一直在经历一段追求健康的历程。我想更好地照顾我的免疫系统和肠道健康。而只需一勺美味的AG1，你基本上就能吸收75种高质量的维他命、矿物质、益生菌以及所有这些好东西。这对你的神经系统和免疫系统真的非常有益。这只是一个你可以融入日常生活中的简单微习惯，却能带来巨大的好处。它非常符合现代生活方式，而且Athletic Greens还是一家碳中和认证企业，
which we absolutely love on the show. Right now, it is time to reclaim your health and arm your immune system with a convenient daily nutrition. It's just one scoop in a cup of water every day. That's it. No need for a million different pills and supplements to look after your health. And to make it easy, Athletic Greens is going to give you a free one-year supply of immune-supporting vitamin D and five free travel packs with your first purchase. All you have to do is visit athletic greens.com slash gemma. Again, that's athletic greens.com slash gemma to take ownership over your health and pick up the ultimate daily nutritional insurance. So what are some of the long-term impacts?
我们在节目中绝对非常喜欢这一点。现在，是时候重拾你的健康，用便捷的日常营养来武装你的免疫系统了。每天只需在杯水中加入一勺即可。就是这样。无需成百上千种不同的药丸和补充剂来维持健康。为了让一切变得简单，Athletic Greens将在你首次购买时免费赠送一年的增强免疫力的维生素D以及五包免费旅行装。你只需要访问athleticgreens.com/gemma。再次强调，那是 athleticgreens.com/gemma，来掌控你的健康，并挑选终极的日常营养保障。那么，有哪些长远影响呢？
what are some of the kind of, what's the significance of holding on to rejection for too long, of letting it kind of have more of a say in our lives than we want? Well, rejection, first of all, has massive ties to our self-esteem. I feel like that's quite self-explanatory. We tie our worth often to things of significance, things like our romantic relationships, like our careers, like our friendships. and with that significance comes a lot of our identity and our self-concept. So when we experience a rejection within one of those domains, within one of those fears,
对于过于执着于被拒绝、让它在我们的生活中拥有超过我们所希望的话语权，到底有什么意义和严重后果呢？首先，被拒绝与我们的自尊心有着巨大的联系。我觉得这相当不言而喻。我们常常将自己的价值与具有重大意义的事物绑定在一起，比如我们的浪漫关系、我们的职业、我们的友谊。而伴随着这种重大意义而来的，是我们的很多身份认同和自我概念。因此，当我们在其中一个领域、其中一个恐惧中经历拒绝时，
it kind of bleeds into how we see ourselves. And it often sends us on a bit of a mission to kind of undermine ourselves. Often when we are rejected romantically, especially, we've talked about this, but we tend to see it as our fault. Like we are in some way inadequate. There's something wrong with us because we're looking for an explanation. We don't always get that from someone else. We're not always able to call them up and be like,
它就会渗透到我们如何看待自己之中。这往往会让我们踏上一条自我贬低的道路。通常，特别是当我们在浪漫关系中被拒绝时，我们已经讨论过这一点，但我们往往会认为这是我们自己的错。就像我们在某种程度上是不合格的。我们身上有什么地方不对劲，因为我们在寻找解释。我们并不总是能从别人那里得到那个解释。我们并不总是能打电话给对方问：
oh, so why exactly didn't you like me? Can you list like the five top reasons so I can go away and fix them? No, and often it has nothing to do with you, but it's a much easier way of defining the situation by thinking about what's wrong with you rather than what might be wrong with the context. Like perhaps it's just a bad fit. You don't have that chemistry. you've got incompatible lifestyles, you've got different wants.
“哦，所以你到底为什么不喜欢我？你能列出前五个原因吗，好让我回去改进？”不能，而且通常这与你毫无关系，但通过思考你身上出了什么问题，而不是思考环境可能出了什么问题，是一种更容易界定局势的方式。比如，也许这只是不适合。你们没有那种化学反应，
But blaming ourselves and attacking ourselves is only going to worsen the emotional state we're in and might actually end up leading to some really harmful behaviours and which we're kind of almost punishing or blaming ourselves, which makes it more difficult for us to emotionally recover and kind of move on. Here's a really interesting fact that I found while researching this. rejection also temporarily lowers our IQ. It sounds strange, but after, so being asked to recall a recent experience of rejection and relive that experience, even if it hadn't occurred right in that moment, it actually made people score lower on IQ tests.
你们的生活方式不兼容，你们有不同的需求。但是责备自己和攻击自己只会恶化我们所处的情感状态，甚至可能最终导致一些真正有害的行为，在这些行为中我们几乎在惩罚或责备自己，这使得我们在情感上更难恢复并继续前行。这里有一个我在做研究时发现的非常有趣的事实：拒绝也会暂时降低我们的IQ（智商）。听起来很奇怪，但在被要求回忆最近一次被拒绝的经历并重温那一经历后，即使它并没有在那个当下发生，也确实让人们在智商测试中得分更低。
So these researchers, they sat people down, they gave them an IQ test, and then they asked them, okay, when was the last time you felt rejected? and they asked them to describe that, to describe how they felt, and then they gave them another IQ test. And they found that people were poorer at short-term memory tests, at decision-making, at being able to respond intelligently after they had recalled that experience because it left them so emotionally drained
因此，这些研究人员让人们坐下来，给他们做了一场智商测试，然后问他们：“好的，你上次感到被拒绝是什么时候？”并让他们描述这一点，描述他们的感受，然后又给他们做了一场智商测试。结果他们发现，人们在回忆了那段经历后，在短期的记忆测试、决策能力以及智能反应方面的表现都变得更差了，因为那让他们在情感上筋疲力尽，
and left their brain so frazzled. So reliving that pain of that rejection, it's actually not doing you much good. You might be looking for like something that went wrong or trying to think about what you could have done differently, but it's actually only kind of hurting and harming our problem-solving skills and our ability to move on. I know it's really hard when we talk about these things to be like,
并且让他们的脑子一团糟。因此，重温被拒绝的痛苦对你并没有什么好处。你可能在寻找哪里出了问题，或者试图思考你可以做出什么不同的举措，但实际上它只会伤害和损害我们的问题解决能力以及我们继续前行的能力。我知道当我们谈论这些事情时，很难去想：“哦，你说的这些负面事情听起来真糟糕，但要我从被拒绝中走出来真的很困难，或者要我把你的话听到心里去真的很困难，因为我们都知道，这并不像创可贴那样有一个简单的解决方案，特别是由于被拒绝是一种无意识的体验。它并非一种——遭受拒绝的体验，与其说是拒绝本身，不如说是我们对它的情绪反应。这并不是我们总能用大脑前额叶、用我们的活跃大脑去处理的事情。
oh, like you're saying all these negative things about how it's terrible, but it's really difficult for me to move on from rejection, or it's really difficult for me to take what you're saying to heart, because as we all know, it's not as easy as this Band-Aid solution, especially because rejection is an unconscious experience. It's not one more the experience of rejection, not so much rejection, but our emotional reaction to it. It's not something we always handle at the front of our brain within our active brain.
这是那种在幕后悄然发生且无意识的事情。甚至在某些情况下，我们可能根本不尊重拒绝我们的人或机构，但它仍然会痛。他们可能是个完全的陌生人，但因为那种渴望被喜欢、渴望成为内群体一员并被接纳的需求是如此强烈，我们在乎它，哪怕只有那么一点点。他们做了一个非常有趣的实验，
It's something that occurs kind of behind the scenes and unconsciously. And even there's situations in which we may not even respect the person or respect the institution that's rejected us, but it still hurts. they might be a total stranger, but because that need to be liked and need to be part of the in-group and be accepted is so strong, we care about it, just that little bit more. They did this a really interesting experiment
他们对这组参与者说：“好了，这些人太糟糕了。他们犯了所有这些罪行。他们做了这些可怕的事情。他们属于仇恨团体。而且他们不喜欢你。”即使我们对那群人毫无敬意，即使他们很糟糕，我们仍然会在乎，人们依然表现出了
where they told this group of participants like, all right, these people are like awful. They've done all these crimes. They've done these awful things. They like belong to hate groups. And they don't like you. And even when we had no respect for the, that group of people, even when they were like awful, we still cared and people still exhibited
情绪反应。我们已经讨论过这一点，但正因为如此，它对我们的自尊心和自我价值感产生了相当严重的影响，正如我们已经解释过的那样。而在我们二十多岁的时候，我们的自我价值感本来就相当不稳定。我们正试图在新的环境中建立我们的身份认同，以及我们从未经历过的环境，通常是远离家人，迈出超越舒适区的一步。自我价值感是我们看待自己的核心所在。因此，如果我们频繁遭到伴侣、我们感兴趣的人或家人的拒绝，我们可能会开始觉得自己是不可爱的，或者不值得被爱。如果我们不断被工作拒绝，我们可能会觉得自己不够熟练或不够聪明。被社交群体拒绝可能会留下
an emotional reaction. We've talked about this a bit, but because of that, it has a pretty severe impact on our self-esteem and our sense of self-worth, as we've kind of already explained. And our self-worth is already quite unstable in our 20s. We're trying to establish our identity and new environments and, you know, environments we've never been before, often away from our family, taking a step beyond our comfort zone. And self-worth, it's at the very core of how we see ourselves. So if we experience frequent rejections from partners or people we're interested in or our family, we may come to see ourselves as unlobable or not worthy of love. If we keep getting rejected from jobs, we may see ourselves as not skilled or intelligent enough. Rejected from social groups can leave
一种情感反应。我们之前讨论过这一点，正因如此，它对我们的自尊和自我价值感产生了相当严重的冲击，就像我们之前已经解释过的那样。在我们二十多岁的时候，自我价值感本来就已经相当不稳定。我们正试图在新的环境中确立自己的身份，而且这些环境往往是我们从未经历过的，通常远离家人，迈出了舒适区的一步。自我价值感是我们如何看待自己的核心。因此，如果我们频繁遭到伴侣、感兴趣的人或家人的拒绝，我们可能会觉得自己不可爱，或者不值得被爱。如果我们不断被工作拒绝，我们可能会觉得自己不够熟练或不够聪明。被社交圈拒绝可能会让人
us feeling on the outside, not cool enough, you know, looking to link it to some aspect of our identity like our physical appearance or our hobbies or our likes. But I think the important lesson is you don't need to change anything about yourself to feel valid and to feel valued. Although rejection is a normal part of life, it's inevitable. Not everyone's going to like you, not everyone's going to see how brilliant you are. It doesn't mean that rejection has to dominate how we see ourselves. So let's discuss some of the ways that we can bounce back from a painful rejection
我们总觉得自己格格不入，不够酷，你知道的，总想把它和我们身份的某个方面联系起来，比如我们的外表、爱好或喜好。但我觉得最重要的教训是，你不需要改变自己的任何地方去感受自我价值和被重视。虽然拒绝是生活中的常态，它是不可避免的。并不是每个人都会喜欢你，并不是每个人都能看到你的闪光点。但这并不意味着拒绝必须主导我们对自己的看法。所以让我们来讨论一些能够帮助我们从痛苦的拒绝中振作起来的方法
rejection experience. There are ways that you can kind of treat the psychological and emotional wounds and scars of rejection. I'm sure we all have an experience from like primary school and when we were like in kindergarten where someone's been like, I don't like you and it sticks with us. It stays in our brains. But we can actually treat that. But to do that, we actually have to understand why it is that that hurt us, what it is that it activates or triggers within us to make us react that way. It's probably something to do with an insecurity that we're dealing with that this experience has kind of agitated in some ways. You know, if you don't see yourself as being conventionally attractive or desirable and someone rejects you, it reconfirms that.
拒绝的经历。你可以通过一些方法来疗愈拒绝带来的心理和情感创伤与疤痕。我确信我们都有过这样的经历，比如在小学或幼儿园的时候，有人对你说了句“我不喜欢你”，然后这句话就一直盘旋在我们心中。它留在了我们的脑海里。但我们其实是可以治愈这种创伤的。不过要做到这一点，我们必须先理解为什么这件事会伤害我们，它在我们内心激活或触发了什么，才让我们做出那样的反应。这可能和我们正在面对的某种不安全感有关，而这种经历在某种程度上激化了它。你知道的，如果你不认为自己具有传统意义上的吸引力或渴望度，而有人拒绝了你，这就再次印证了这一点。
And it also makes it hurt more because you're like, oh, I really don't. already knew this about myself, it shouldn't be this painful. But it also, you know, that scar is already a pretty open one. You know, it's something that can be picked at even more. Or, you know, if we don't get a job, we might, the reason that that might hurt more is because of a deeper psychological wound to, you know, maybe to deal with imposter syndrome or maybe to do with a sense that you're not skilled enough or a sense that you've never been intelligent enough. So, overcoming rejection actually takes time and it takes an investment in identifying what it is that we're vulnerable towards and about, what it is that we're insecure about, that this
这也让痛苦加剧，因为你会想，“哦，我其实早就知道自己有这个问题，它本不该这么痛苦的。”但同时，你知道，那道伤疤本来就是一个还没有完全愈合的伤口。你知道的，它是那种可以被进一步揭开的痛点。或者，如果我们没有得到一份工作，之所以会感觉更痛，可能是因为更深层的心理创伤，比如可能是为了应对冒名顶替综合症，或者可能是觉得自己的技能不够，或者觉得自己从来不够聪明。因此，克服拒绝实际上需要时间，也需要投入去找出我们的脆弱点和不安点到底是什么，究竟是什么样的事情经由这次
experience has kind of leveraged and made worse. But I think one of the greatest things that we as humans have the ability to do is to change our minds and shift our perspectives. So what if we chose to view rejection as a gift rather than as this like painful thing that we need to avoid? It's kind of what cognitive behavioral therapy tries to do. It tries to change how we think about something which in turn changes, how we react to it. So let's kind of do a thought experiment about how we can do this with rejection. Of course, if you've experienced a rejection, there's going to be a period of self-loathing.
经历被放大并变得更加糟糕。但我认为，人类拥有的最伟大的能力之一就是改变我们的思想和转变我们的视角。如果我们选择把拒绝视为一份礼物，而不是那种我们需要极力避开的痛苦事物，会怎么样呢？这正是认知行为疗法试图做的事情。它试图改变我们对某事的看法，进而改变我们对它的反应。所以让我们做一个思想实验，看看我们如何能对拒绝做到这一点。当然，如果你经历过拒绝，必然会有一段自我厌恶的时期。
And you might take that experience and be like, well, it's something wrong with me and that's that. But you might also see it as an opportunity to understand yourself better, to understand those insecurities we were talking about, to pursue a new opportunity, something that you hadn't even thought of. If we think about it, even in like kind of a mystical way of like this was meant to happen from the universe or like this was supposed to happen, we change our mindset away from being like, this is because I am terrible, this is because I'm not. attractive or I am not skilled or intelligent or lovable and we change it to something else something
你可能会把这段经历当作“嗯，我身上就是有什么问题，就这样了”。但你也可以把它看作是一个更好地了解自己的机会，去理解我们刚才谈到的那些不安全感，去追求一个新的机遇——甚至是那些你从未想过的事物。如果我们换个角度去想，哪怕是用一种更玄学的方式，比如“这是宇宙注定要发生的”或者“这就是命运的安排”，我们就会把心态从“这是因为我很糟糕，这是因为我没有吸引力，或者我没有技能、不够聪明、不讨人喜欢”转变成别的东西，一种
of like this is actually has nothing to do with me and everything to do with divine timing everything to do with new opportunities and we're able to take what is like a pretty shitty situation and use it for personal growth use it for improvement use it to change how we view the world and how we view bad things that happen to us so I think some tips some very actionable tips that I would is firstly, give yourself time to feel shit about it. Like, it is the, like, I think when we jump the gun and try and move on, often that's unconscious suppression of the actual experience, which is quite harmful. It's a negative coping mechanism.
类似于“这其实跟我一点关系也没有，这全都是命运最好的安排，全都是为了迎接新的机遇”，然后我们就能把这种相当糟糕的状况转化为个人成长的契机，转化为改进的途径，用来改变我们看待世界的方式以及看待降临在我们身上的坏事的方式。所以我想分享一些非常实用的建议，首先是：给自己留出时间去为这件糟糕的事情难过。因为，你知道，当我们急于求成并试图快速翻篇时，通常那是对真实经历的无意识压抑，而这其实相当有害。这是一种消极的应对机制。
We're like, oh, you know, I'm so over it. Who cares? Fuck them, whatever. But it's like, no, that's not you actually having time to validate and experience your feelings. It's you just trying to suppress them. And we know that this is just going to come back and harm us later on. So it's better to give yourself permission to feel the sting, to feel the pain, feel resentment if you have to, you know, be mad at the situation if you have to.
我们可能会说，“哦，你知道的，我已经彻底走出来了。谁在乎呢？去他的吧，随便啦。”但事实并非如此，这并不是在真正花时间去确认并体验你的感受。这只是你在试图压抑它们。我们都知道，这种做法在以后只会卷土重来并伤害我们。所以最好还是给自己许可去感受这种刺痛，去感受痛苦，如果有必要的话去感受怨恨，如果有必要的话去对这种处境感到愤怒。
But don't put yourself down in the process. Don't include your self-worth in that equation and limit the time you spend on it. You know, giving yourself time doesn't mean giving yourself endless time to ruminate. and feel really crap and let it become a part of your identity. So think about what's next instead. Romantic rejection. Think about how much time you have with your friends. Academic university rejection.
但在经历这个过程时不要贬低自己。不要把你的自我价值算进这个等式里，并且限制你在上面花时间。你知道，给自己时间并不意味着给你无限的时间去反刍痛苦、感觉糟糕并让它成为你身份的一部分。所以转而思考下一步该做什么。浪漫关系上的拒绝。想想你有多少时间可以和朋友们在一起。学业或大学申请的拒绝。
Hell, you've got a new community. You've got a new learning pathway. Like you didn't get into medical school. Great, you can become a dentist. Or you can go and do something entirely different. You could be a graphic designer. I'm sure you've got very steady hands. Familiar rejection.
见鬼，你拥有了一个新的社群。你有了新的学习途径。比如你没有考上医学院？太棒了，你可以去当牙医。或者你可以去做完全不同的事。你可以成为一名平面设计师。我敢肯定你的手一定很稳。家庭方面的拒绝。
That's a huge one. it's about reminding yourself that you can create your own family. It's not just blood. It's not who you were born surrounded by. And reminding ourselves that there is not just one path towards happiness. Remember, like we said at the beginning, rejection is just a redirection. So think about what's next. And think about the opportunities that you maybe wouldn't have had if that thing had gone right.
这是一个大问题。关键是要提醒自己，你可以创造属于你自己的家庭。它不仅限于血缘。它不取决于你出生时周围都是什么人。我们要提醒自己，通往幸福的道路绝不止一条。记住，就像我们在开头所说的那样，拒绝只是一种重定向。所以去思考下一步是什么。去想想那些如果没有发生这件事，你可能根本不会拥有的机遇。
You know, if you had dated that person, maybe you wouldn't have met your current partner or you wouldn't be able to go on like amazing first dates and see new places in your city or meet new people. Rejection is a redirection. It is a positive thing and if we change our attitudes towards it and we have that mindset shift of turning loss into action and building inner strength and resilience, we're probably going to be stronger people in the long run. So how do we do this? Well, it kind of depends on what type of rejection we've experienced. But often it's about relating back to the core parts of ourselves that we value, reconnecting with your sense of self-worth and reminding yourself of what your strengths are,
你知道的，如果你当时和那个人约会了，也许你就不会遇到现在的伴侣，或者你就无法去经历那些美妙的初次约会、探索你所在城市的全新去处或结识新朋友。拒绝是一种重定向。这是一件积极的事情，如果我们改变对它的态度，实现将失败转化为行动、建立内心力量和韧性的心态转变，从长远来看，我们很可能会成为更强大的人。那么我们该如何做到这一点呢？这在很大程度上取决于我们经历了哪种类型的拒绝。但通常这都关乎回归到我们所珍视的核心自我部分，重新连接你的自我价值感，并提醒自己你的优势是什么，
make a list, ask your family and friends, like, what am I good at? What do you like about me? What do I love doing? What are the things that make me me? Even if people can't, you know, certain people can't see your worth, it means that you're able to. And I think every person is so incredibly unique and like, oh my God, so special and beautiful and amazing. Someone's going to recognize that about you. And even if they don't,
列个清单，问问你的家人和朋友，“我擅长什么？你们喜欢我什么？我热爱做什么？是什么造就了独一无二的我？”即使其他人——你知道的，某些人——看不到你的价值，这也意味着你自己能够看到。而且我认为每个人都是如此的独一无二，天哪，是如此的特别、美丽和惊艳。总会有人认可你身上的这一点。即使他们没有，
you're going to be able to. And I say it probably like every third episode, but that relationship you have with yourself is so important. It's more important than whether other people like you. I think building resilience may also be like finding your strengths, building new strengths, working to grow and build pre-existing things you're good at, build them even more. Like if you're someone who's like amazing at something, spend time on that. Make that such an asset about yourself and reach out to people who love and support you. I think that's a really great way to avoid seeking almost the comfort of limiting beliefs or self-blame because they're really easy, right? It's easier to find an explanation within as to why something didn't work out or why
你自己也能做到。我大概每三期节目就会说一次，你与自己的关系是如此重要。它比其他人是否喜欢你更重要。我认为培养韧性也可能意味着：发现你的优势，培养新的优势，努力成长并巩固你原本擅长的领域，让它们变得更强大。比如如果你在某件事上表现得非常出色，就在那上面花时间。把这变成你身上的独特资产，并向那些爱护和支持你的人寻求帮助。我认为这是一个非常好的方法，可以避免去寻求那些限制性信念或自我责怪的安慰，因为这些真的很容易产生，对吧？在一件事情为什么没有成功或为什么
you experienced rejection, then have to kind of think about all the other possibilities. And sometimes there's no easy solution. There's no easy answer. So the easiest solution is to relate it to your personal attributes, which is so harmful. And it can make the experience so much worth. So I think believing in your abilities, believing in your worth and surrounding yourself with people who encourage you and encourage that feeling within you, even if that means, you know, cutting ties with a toxic workplace or cutting ties with a toxic friend, it's going to pay off in the long run. And I know that can be incredibly difficult. But taking the time now, when we're young, to invest in that perspective building is going to be such a great investment for your future.
你经历了拒绝时，从内部找一个解释往往更容易，总比去思考所有其他可能性要轻松。有时候根本没有简单的解决方案。没有简单的答案。所以最简单的解决办法就是把它归咎于你的个人特质，而这极具破坏性。它会让这段经历变得更加糟糕。所以我想，坚信你的能力，坚信你的价值，并用那些鼓励你、激发你这种感觉的人环绕着你——即使这意味着，你知道的，切断与有毒的工作场所的联系，或者切断与有毒的朋友的联系——从长远来看都是值得的。我知道这可能极其困难。但现在正当我们年轻时，花时间去建立这种视角，将为你未来的发展带来巨大的回报。
Because rejection is inevitable. But the emotional and negative emotional reaction in that low self-esteem doesn't have to be if we take the time to see these experiences as being external rather than due to internal personal factors. and you know what i believe in you i believe in your journey i know i've said it so many times in this episode but every single time i have felt rejection and found myself ruminating and stuck in a negative loop i always emerge from it not only like a stronger version of myself but with this incredible realization that sometimes things don't work out because they weren't meant to and there's always another brilliant opportunity around the corner something better for you even if you have to wait for it it's better to wait and be pleasantly surprised and happier with that situation than
因为拒绝是不可避免的。但如果我们花时间把这些经历看作是外部的，而不是归咎于内部的个人因素，那么情绪化的、消极的情绪反应以及由此带来的低自尊就不一定会发生。你知道吗，我相信你，我相信你的旅程。我知道我在这一期节目里已经说过很多次了，但每当我经历拒绝、发现自己陷入反刍和负面情绪循环中时，我总是能不仅以一个更强大的自己的姿态走出来，而且带着这样一个不可思议的顿悟：有时事情没有成功，是因为它们本来就不是为你准备的，转角处总会有另一个绝佳的机会，总会有更适合你的事物在等着你，哪怕你必须为此等待。等待并迎来惊喜，对那种情况感到更加快乐，总好过
kind of settle for something else. You know, maybe that's to do with friends. Like you're feeling like you don't really have a group of friends right now. You're feeling rejected. Instead of trying to make them like you and molding your behaviours to them, just tittle out for a little bit. I'm sure there's people around the corner who you can't force friendships with, but they'll show up and they will love you.
勉强接受别的东西。你知道的，这可能也关乎朋友。比如你觉得自己现在并没有真正的朋友圈子。你感到了被拒绝。与其去试图讨好他们、根据他们来塑造自己的行为，不如先退一步。我确信转角处就会有志同道合的人，你无法强求友谊，但他们会出现，并且会爱你的。
There's more than one path to happiness. set it. There's more than one path to happiness. There are so many solutions and other options for you to explore. There are actions that you can take to better yourself, to better your skills without necessarily, you know, deciding that, you know, that you're terrible and you need to fix something. Like, it's all about a strength-based approach. Like, you already are amazing at this. You're already fantastic. So let's take those skills. Let's take that, you know, amazing personality attribute you have or that lovable attribute and turn it into something even more brilliant. Thank you so much for listening to this episode. I really hope you enjoyed it. I really enjoyed
通往幸福的道路不止一条。我已经说过了。通往幸福的道路不止一条。有无数的解决方案和备选方案等待你去探索。你可以采取行动来完善自我、提升技能，而不必非得——你知道的——断定自己一无是处、必须去修补什么。这一切都关乎基于优势的方法。比如，你在这方面已经很棒了。你已经非常出色了。所以让我们利用这些技能。让我们把你拥有的那种——你知道的——惊人的个性特质或讨人喜欢的特质，转化为更加闪耀的成果。非常感谢大家收听本期节目。我真的希望你们会喜欢。我真的很享受
researching it. As someone who has often dealt with rejection and perhaps not always taken it the best way, blamed myself, seen myself as lacking something or deficient in something because of it, it was so enlightening to have like this information. I think that's the thing that I love doing with this show is being able to make those educational and psychological aspects of it so much more accessible so that we can have that kind of psychoeducation and that knowledge of what we're going through. And I promise if you're someone who's experiencing romantic or social rejection right now, it's an opportunity.
做这个课题的研究。作为一个经常面对拒绝、或许并不总是能以最好的方式处理它、会责怪自己、并因此觉得自己有所欠缺或有缺陷的人，能获得这些信息是如此的启迪人心。我想这正是我热爱这档节目的原因，能够把那些教育和心理学方面的知识变得更加平易近人，这样我们就能进行那种心理学普及，并对我们正在经历的事情有所认知。我向你保证，如果你现在正经历浪漫关系或社交上的拒绝，这其实是一个机遇。
It's such an opportunity. There's going to be something much better around the corner. I really do believe it. As always, if you did enjoy this episode, please feel free to leave it a five-star rating on Apple Podcasts or Spotify Podcasts, Samsung Podcasts. I don't know. I don't know where you're listening.
这真的是一个巨大的机遇。转角处一定会有更好得多的事物在等待着你。我真的坚信这一点。一如既往，如果你确实喜欢本期节目，请随时在苹果播客、Spotify播客或三星播客上留下五星好评。我也不确定。我不知道你是在哪里听的。
But please feel free to leave it a review. If you feel cool to do so, it really helps the show to grow and to reach new people if you think that they would like to hear this message. And thank you so much for your support recently. I'm like, I'm blown away. I really do know how to say thank you enough. There's so many new people listening to the show.
但请随心所欲地留下你的评论。如果你愿意这么做的话，它真的能极大地帮助节目成长，并触达更多可能想听这段讯息的新听众。非常感谢大家最近对我的支持。我真的——我简直惊呆了。我真的不知道该如何表达我的谢意。有那么多新听众在收听这个节目。
And I know so many of you, a friend, recommended this to you. So thank you so much. And I'll be back next week with a new episode. Have a lovely week. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%.
而且我知道你们当中有很多人都是经由朋友推荐才知道这里的。所以非常感谢大家。我会在下周带着新节目回归。祝大家有个愉快的一周。2%。这就是当旁边有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，
I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我将剖析精神坚韧度、体能训练以及在我们这个奇特现代世界中建立韧性的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。也就是 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方的 TWA%。
On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick you here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors.
在《Look Back at it》播客中。从1979年开始，对我来说那是意义重大的一刻。1984年对我也意义重大。我是萨姆·J（Sam J）。我是亚历克斯·英格lish（Alex English）。在每一期节目中，我们都会带你回到过去，剖析当年发生了什么，并试着和我们的朋友、喜剧演员同行以及最喜欢的作家们一起，弄清楚我们是如何挺过那一切的。
Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way
比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）聊80年代。1984年是个疯狂的年份。那确实是个疯狂的年份。我认为对于黑人来说，再没有比这更重要的年份了。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家好，你们正在收听的是《从头学起》（Learn the Hard Way），
with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that's really, not safe to have anywhere, but you're having him with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the iHeart radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. This is an iHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
主播是你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·加姆斯（Kear Games）。这个空间聚焦于黑人男性的经历，进行那些在其他任何地方进行都不太安全的坦诚对话，但你是在和一个懂行的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着一套精神盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。而仅仅因为你具备这种防御能力，并不意味着你就必须使用它。请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。这是一个 iHeart 播客。保证真人制作。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。